hey everybody it's Mike freder with on
call compliance Solutions and I'm back
with another compliance tip of the week
this week we're talking about cmmc
control si. L1
d314 4 oh we're getting there update
malicious code protection mechanisms
when new releases are available I love
the easy
[Music]
ones so hey if you're a defense
contractor who's feeling overwhelmed
tired and alone trying to understand all
this cmmc DS and n00 171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you because you found your home here at
on call compliance Solutions where we
can help you transform into your
company's on call compliance Hero Let's
jump into it love it love it love it
love it should be automatic I love this
control but is it no your team should be
verifying and documenting on a periodic
basis that patches and updates are in
fact being installed and updates are
successful on a periodic basis you just
can't trust automation I promise ask
anyone who's ever lost data in a backup
okay it was set up it was automated
didn't really quite work long term all
right you got to verify it this stuff
does require a human touch uh let's see
what the assessors are looking for on
this one it's pretty straightforward
just one thing they're looking for it's
determine if malicious code protection
mechanisms are updated when new releases
are available and what they're going to
want to do they're going to want to
actually see your system and you're
going to have to show them that updates
have in fact been applied on time and
there's something that's automating that
so uh if we were to give a sample answer
we'd say hey it's implemented it's
enforced and monitored via the endpoint
management update uh automatic updates
and verified by you know it humans uh
every so often right so an answer like
that would work just fine now uh if
you're not sure what endpoint management
system to use if you are trying to
figure out exactly what will satisfy
these controls from a tech stack
perspective or even if you're a CEO or a
CIO who's just really trying to figure
out how to get this whole thing solved
quickly the great news is at on call we
work with defense contractors just like
you whove had this defar nist itar and
cmmc compliance stuff dropped right in
their laps like a seagull on a sunny day
we teach you how to level up and be a
proper on call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps great areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance as your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that's
what becoming on call compliance hero
can do for you if you're looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit cmmc compliance.com or
check out the bio below for links to get
help right now if you love the content
we're putting out here for you help us
out with a big thumbs up on that like
button or even better You Guessed It
smash that subscribe button to get the
latest compliance content as soon as our
compliance ear roll it out until the
next compliance tip my friends stay safe
and secure out there and hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance I'll
see you on the next
[Music]
one